conan's son and my daughter go to school
together that's right and uh you've been
pushing the irish thing on him i know
this for a fact because he constantly
brings my sadie back behind the tree and
goes take a look at my shoulder no he
does he does
it's ridiculous that's ridiculous
a little bad boy you know what i love is
that there are these events we have at
the school where they get the dads
involved and one of the ones you and i
always do is where they get us up there
at like 6 30 7 o'clock in the morning to
make pancakes for the kids like twice a
year they get us to do it and it's
really funny because you walk around in
a bathrobe and like wrap around
sunglasses you're like hey buddy
yeah yeah yeah i know conan works hard
on those conan is very competitive when
it comes to these uh pancake things i
made pancakes with some kids and they
were going nuts the first graders were
like hey mr sandler those are the best
pancakes i ever had hey man you're
you're incredible dude i was like yeah
that's right baby and then uh cohen and
caesars and gets all shook up the next
week makes him pot pancakes
this is the best
[Applause]
i wanted to win you know he got a win
he's the winner uh did you go away for
easter break at all it was just a big
break we were in atlanta working but you
were doing anything fun i wanted to to
come with you but uh yeah we took the uh
a few different things we took the kids
skiing by the way you have you brought
the children that's a lot of work right
yeah yeah getting them dressed and
everything and having to bend over and
buckle their boots yeah oh my god
i was like buckle buckle your own boots
and they're like
but anyways
andy uh yes and and and boys good to see
you all
love you guys all right so we uh i go i
take them to uh uh uh
they keep sitting at the front desk in
wyoming you gotta go i forget the name
of the place i think it's called the
game lodge or something like that gotta
go to the game lodge everybody goes to
the game lot so i bring the kids to the
game lodge and it's like we walk into
place and it's a restaurant and it's all
these like stuffed buffaloes and
you know like animals all over elk and
heads here and all kinds of stuff yeah
it's pretty cool and i'm like oh check
this out and then i see my kids kind of
like
like getting tense and i was like oh boy
this is gonna go bad i think and then
they so we sit down they're like why why
are they all like that i said oh they uh
you know they those are
the they're fake they're not fake i
don't know but maybe they are no but
they're real maybe they are real but
they
but they did not get shot yeah how they
died they were sick
and they were the kids were like no no
no they were not sick and then i was
like well maybe they got shot but you
know
kindly
sweetly shot and well and then my kids
started freaking out and it was the
worst and it's all these these real stud
guys in there like real men with
mustaches and uh and they were like
seeing my kids screaming and screaming
at me and i was like you don't have to
eat that you don't have to eat anything
you can have uh you know a hamburger and
then i was like oh my god i never told
them what a hamburger is
and then and then i see my older ones
like what is
a hamburger
she doesn't talk to me
lovely girl doesn't talk that way why is
he so
anyways i dropped an honor it's got it's
you know some cow in there but
it's
it's
mixed with goodness
and rainbows she started screaming and
crying and both of them were screamed my
two little girls were screaming and
crying and then i my wife was nice
enough to take him outside i was like
just take them on they hate it here but
i already ordered so i'm like well let
me finish my steak
and i'll see you out there so
jackie takes him takes him home we go
home i'm like maybe they'll forget about
that the next morning i'm on the
elevator and uh sadie the older one goes
uh
who on this elevator is a vegetarian
and
all three of them raised a hand and i
start raising mine and then she goes
liar
[Laughter]